at a Maximum Security Prison some 250
kilometers east of Moscow the gaunt
figure of Alexei navalny appeared before
the court the same prison where he is
already serving sentences that amount to
11 and a half years for convictions
including fraud and contempt of court
yet navalny now faces up to 30 more
years behind bars as he defended himself
against the new charges that include
inciting and financing extremist
activity and creating an extremist
organization
yes I believe that given the
circumstances for all of us in terms of
legal and criminal procedure you should
of course recuse yourself because it is
obvious to all of us that in this
process your Independence to put it
mildly is seriously Limited
after the trial opened in public
journalists were told to leave and it
continued behind closed doors observing
from a room next to the court his father
said the proceedings had no shame no
conscience no honor
oh
for more than a decade navalny has been
one of the highest profile political
opponents of President Vladimir Putin
and the target of several legal cases in
2020 navalny survived an apparent
attempt to poison him during a flight in
Siberia tests undertaken at laboratories
in Sweden and France concluded it was a
nerve agent while navalny accused the
Russian state of trying to kill him the
Kremlin denied any involvement
after his recuperation in Germany he
returned to Moscow and was arrested upon
his arrival
I supporters mobilized in cities across
Russia but were faced with a police
Crackdown most of his people closest
allies have fled Russia and those who
didn't like himself been put in prison
so essentially the bottom line is that
any open position activity
which goes for either Mass disturbances
or tries to undermine the government is
now not possible to do from within
Russia
while weakened navalny's organization
continues its work to oppose the Russian
government as he remains Behind Bars
but the war in Ukraine has now taken
precedence over his release once an
essential conversation point between
Western leaders and Putin and his fate
in the hands of the Russian Judicial
System Sonia Gallego Al Jazeera